- Yeah, I wanna ask you
about the Bitcoin slash crypto boom,
that we've seen over the
last couple of years.
It's problematic at best in so many ways.
- Can you do the face?
- No way.
I cheer for you daily.
This is not a debate.
- Gary Vee is in the studio.
(cheering)
- Yes, I do have an out
of the blue quick take.
Always be grateful,
always push yourself
for the next ambition.
- [Audience] Gary, Gary,
Gary, Gary, Gary, Gary!
Gary, Gary!
- It's cool.
If you do not love losing, you lost.
♪ I feel I can't lose ♪
♪ Immortal, immortal, immortal ♪
(mellow music)
- To me it's about living
within your own self.
I think the biggest
issue for so many people
is they over worry about
validation from the outside.
Whether it's about their appearance,
whether it's about how
much money they make,
whether it's to make their parents proud,
which is a nice thing.
The only way to actually get to that place
that you really want to get to
is putting your fingers in your ears
and living in your own world.
The cocoon you create for yourself
is the place that you can be most happy.
Because when you actually
need outside validation,
you will always, always be vulnerable.
(mellow music)
♪ Okay, cool ♪
♪ Brand new coop and it just got tinted ♪
- Right now we're gonna
be going to Dubai Eye
to record an interview.
Dubai Eye is mostly the business channel,
so basically we're just talking
to them about your book,
why you're here in
Dubai, this is recorded.
And then you're gonna
go live on Kris Fade,
and last time they did
something super fun.
- We surprised that girl.
- You surprised that girl.
You were hiding underneath the desk,
and then we're heading
over to the arts club
where we got YPO.
And then we have a big crypto get together
with some of the key
people in the industry,
so that'll be fun.
♪ Hey, we finna charge ♪
♪ East side, them nigga love it ♪
♪ The west side, them nigga love it ♪
♪ North side (indistinct) ♪
- [Presenter] Some people don't
maybe have the disposition,
or, perhaps they don't react
well to the dopamine levels
that get released when you
chase attention, if you like,
on social media.
What do you say to people who
are struggling balancing that?
- That long before
social media came along,
humans struggled with that balance.
Dopamines have come in many forms,
including interacting
with other human beings.
This narrative that is quite popular,
which is blaming technology
for your struggles,
is a losing game.
I wanna remind everybody who's listening,
that only 30 years ago we
would blame the television.
We would blame magazines
showing models at 90 pounds
as a bad force.
And all the things we
today try to point fingers
towards social media platforms,
which I wanna remind everybody,
are completely empty vessels
that human beings fill information with.
Is something that has
been historically true.
There was a time and age
that I could have sat
in this exact studio in the 1960s,
and you would ask me questions of, "Gary,
what do you say about the situation
where we have the Beatles
in Elvis disproportionately
impacting children and believing in this
rock and roll thing."
This is human evolution.
We continue to be incredibly infatuated
with finding ways to point
fingers towards the current,
without pointing thumbs to ourselves.
And leaning into accountability
and self-awareness
of how to deal with the macro.
And I think I'm very
empathetic to people's concerns
about the amount of time that children
and other humans spend on this platform.
I wanna remind people that there is
incredible good from those things.
There are people who spend
time face timing their elders
in different countries because of
technology and social media.
So I think we're in the current state
where we're looking for the
shortcomings of the platform,
which of course there are
because human beings have shortcomings.
- We're going live, good morning, 8:02.
Gary Vee is in the studio.
(group cheering)
♪ Going up ♪
♪ Something in my cup ♪
♪ What the fuck ♪
♪ That shit had me stuck ♪
- Can we talk about accountability?
- [Kris] Yeah, sure.
- Talk about something the
world desperately needs.
We wanna blame the algorithm,
we wanna blame our parents,
we wanna blame the government,
we wanna blame everything.
- [Kris] Yep.
- We have become addicted
with pointing fingers,
and nobody wants to point
the thumb at themselves.
I believe most people's unhappiness
that are listening right now
are completely predicated on
their lack of accountability.
If you are unhappy you are actually
in a position to fix it.
If you are listening to this,
you are of the means to fix it, right?
You're not happy about your boyfriend?
Break up with him.
You don't like the country you're in?
Move.
And here's the point whether
you're right or wrong,
your mother might be poisonous.
But the second you take control
of it you become happier.
I think everything is my fault.
I'm logical to know that
not everything is my fault,
but the default of thinking
everything is my fault
actually makes me happy.
(mellow music)
- That was fun.
- So fun.
All right, we just banged
out a bunch of radio,
and it felt good.
I've been out of practice,
I haven't done a lot of
content in a long time.
And so I always feel fresh,
I think for a lot of you,
even Mike when I'm working out
says a rest day is sometimes good.
Even if you love what you do,
the concept of just taking a break from it
just to relike is interesting.
And I always feel that when
I haven't been on stage,
or I haven't done podcast or content,
and I'm enjoying that high
of being back on track.
- Good morning everyone.
Thank you all for turning up.
You say a lot in your
book and in your content
that you care more about happiness
than you do about business.
Yet, you're so successful with business.
- I'm fascinated by human's delusion
that money buys happiness.
I guarantee every person in this room
knows several extremely wealthy people
who are remarkably unhappy.
And so I think that for me
living within your means
is a conversation that has been long lost.
Again, looking around the room,
some of us might remember the concept
of living within your means.
But that is a lost art people live in debt
and they just live.
And so I've always been very fascinated
by the concept of happiness,
because I think it's extremely achievable
when you are capable of not
needing outside validation.
So I think a lot of people
are incredibly vulnerable,
because they need money to buy things,
to impress people they don't even like.
Truly achieving happiness
creates longevity.
(audience applauding)
(mellow Spanish music)
Salmon.
Let me tell you what the biggest
vulnerability of NFTs are,
it's the reason Beanie Babies collapsed.
Anything that is built solely
on the financial interest
is always doomed from the beginning.
So many of my friends
are starting play-to-earn
because it's a psychology, right?
It makes sense.
The problem is it's actually a commodity,
it wasn't a commodity
when it was Axie Infinity
and nobody else was doing it.
It becomes immediately commoditized
when every day there's 600
play-to-earn games being built.
So I think what you need to think about is
play-to-earn is nice,
but how you fill that bucket,
and why people are gonna
care about those characters
is the whole thing.
For me VeeFriends is an
intellectual property exercise
grounded in NFTs.
It could have been grounded in books,
it could have been grounded in toys,
it could have been
grounded in video games,
commercials, cartoons, movies.
It just happens to be grounded in NFTs
because it was the
opportunity in front of me.
I think that's how you have to approach
your play-to-earn business.
- [Host] Absolutely amazing.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(mellow music)
I definitely believe that
people are struggling to admit
that their digital life is more important
than their physical life.
Because it seems challenging,
it seems like that's bad.
I had a friend who really
came at me on the NFT thing,
a good friend, in a fun
way, a fun, good debate.
He's like, "This is the stupidest thing
you've ever supported."
It took me six seconds to win the debate.
I said, "You've asked me
to get you a blue check
on Instagram for three years."
I'm like, "Why?
Why do you want a blue check on Instagram?
Because you just told me this is stupid,
because you can't hold it.
You can't hold your blue check.
You value your digital presence so much
that you think that's validation."
We always demonize the current,
and we put the past on a pedestal.
So I definitely believe that people
are misunderstanding their digital life,
but they're living it.
♪ So I skip straight
ahead to the bread part ♪
♪ Top dog, I'm cool on a ♪
What's good everybody?
I am here in Dubai, D Rock is here.
We're in the region, we love all of you.
I hope I run into all of
you and I miss all of you.
Happy, happy, happy day.
I don't know if you know this D Rock,
but I'm one of the great
Frogger players of all time.
So we're about to play actual
Frogger on this highway.
And I could tell you right now,
I'm gonna dominate these Dubai cars
like nobody's fucking business.
(retro gaming music)
- [Maha] You were a little nervous.
- No I wasn't.
(disappointing music)
That's a good photo.
♪ Keep it playing, keep it pushing ♪
♪ Keep 'em guessing keep 'em looking ♪
♪ Keep my people locked and booking ♪
♪ 'Cause we legendary ♪
♪ I just talk it how I live it ♪
♪ If I said it, then I meant it ♪
♪ If I did it, then I did
it 'cause it's necessary ♪
♪ Keep it G and keep it shooter ♪
♪ You just act like
this ain't new to you ♪
♪ I treat it like it's
usual, we legendary ♪
♪ I just get it how I live it ♪
♪ If I said it then I meant it ♪
♪ If I did it then I did
it 'cause it's necessary ♪
♪ Look, all my ♪
- What do you think is the next thing?
We had mobile phones right now.
we had computers, and tablets,
and the personal assistants before that.
What do you think the next big thing is?
Because they are stagnated right now.
- Very stagnant.
Apple's phone is basically the same.
I don't know,
'cause it's not a space
to spend a lot of time on.
But what I would tell you is,
I'd be stunned if we don't
evolve into robots, stunned.
I think in the next 100 years
if you show me a human being,
I'm like, "That's a robot."
I think I personally know dozens of people
that would implant into
their body technology.
- Yeah, I have done that already (laughs).
- You have?
- Yeah.
- How so?
- A chip.
- [Maha] You have a chip
in your body right now?
- Yeah.
- [Maha] And what are you tracking?
- Nothing. I just use it for payments,
for card exchange, things like that.
They do it in Sweden, it's nothing new.
There are some countries that
are actually doing biometrics
even for payments, like in the UK.
- I love it, I would do it.
♪ Like a general ♪
♪ Hit the cost of Florida ♪
♪ Feeling sort of like a (indistinct) ♪
♪ No exaggeration all my
literature be literal ♪
♪ Little do they know I do ♪
Oh shit, what's this?
- [Maha] I know.
- [Guide] They're all lining
up for you by the way.
- And what am I doing, a talk?
- [Guide] Yeah.
- Amazing.
It's not hard to produce
content for six platforms,
it's really not.
It's that people fear
lack of success in numbers
from a vanity standpoint,
which stops them from actually doing it.
So I think humility is one
of the true superpowers
of a scaled influencer or content creator.
Being okay with starting at zero,
or being okay if the
content's not doing great.
Yes, it's important to be
contextual to the platform,
but not at the expense
of your authenticity.
I'd rather you deliver
the way you would deliver
on Twitter and LinkedIn on TikTok
and let the chips fall where they may,
than for you to not be who you are.
And so the biggest reason
people didn't go to TikTok
when they were winning on Instagram
was they didn't have the
humility and the self-confidence
to not be successful
on TikTok immediately.
- Sure.
Thank you.
- Having your self-esteem
wrapped up in outside validation
is always the greatest vulnerability.
Do everything for
yourself and your family,
not to impress people
that you don't even know.
- A special announcement,
special announcement.
If you don't get the
joke why I'm pointing up
you need to follow me on TikTok.
Anyway, check out the
Monday to Monday this week,
it's a playlist Gary Vee
and I update every Monday.
And this week we have a special artist,
his name's Chico Curly Head, okay?
Gary Vee and I just went
to Atlanta on Monday,
we met up with Lil Dirk,
Chico Curly Head came with us.
And Chico's super special, okay?
He dropped a new project, go stream it,
you'll see what I'm talking about.
He's from Panama, lives in Atlanta.
One of the songs is called "How It Goes".
And on the hook he
says, "I'm from Atlanta,
you know how that goes?"
And if you're from Atlanta,
you already know how that goes.
So check it out, let us know,
let us know your feedback.
Anyway, back to WeeklyVee.
♪ I'm from Atlanta, you
know how that goes ♪
♪ You see how we get it,
you see how it goes ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Hey, hey ♪
- Where's the line between
being satisfied and being ambitious?
- That's a great question.
Satisfied is a complicated word,
what I would argue is being content
and grateful for what you have,
and not envious for what you don't have.
While still being ambitious
is a different way to think
about being satisfied.
Being satisfied I actually think
is too close to be complacent.
I think when you are content
and grateful for what you have
while still staying ambitious,
that's a better and more
sustainable framework.
Never be satisfied, always be grateful,
always push yourself
for the next ambition.
- Amazing, thank you so much Gary.
- Cheers.
- I know that a
huge crowd was waiting for you down.
- Thank you.
- [Maha] Gary, Dr. Mowan was
explaining to you this car.
- [Dr. Mowan] This is an art
car that I told you about.
- [Gary] Oh, this was it.
- [Dr. Mowan] So this is the car.
This is the artwork and
it's dynamic artwork.
There's an augmented reality part of it,
which is actually moving.
And also you drive the same car
in the virtual world as well.
- [Gary] It's very cool, cheers.
- And what would be amazing
if we could have this signed by you.
- Sure, happy to do it.
♪ You see how it goes ♪
(man singing in Spanish)
Always approach everything you
hear that is new with maybe,
because I think what you're feeling
from a lot of your friends
right now with Web3
is the world is intoxicated
with seeing new things
and answering no.
And what has boded so well
for me over the last 25 years
is I go, "Maybe."
Then put in the work and most of the time
come up with a conclusion of no.
It's when you come up
with a conclusion of yes,
after you started with maybe
and you did the homework
where all the magic happens.
So approach every new thing that you hear
with the concept of maybe.
And then have the humility,
this is the big one,
have the humility to put in the work.
Because your time is not
as valuable as you think
to pass on the next thing
that's gonna change the world.
- [Fan] I'm currently
19 years old, all right?
And I started my business,
I took a gap from my high school.
Because all of my friends
they're in colleges right now,
so what do I do right now?
Should I continue my
business, should I do college?
What would be successful here?
- You should continue your business.
- [Fan] And not do college?
- Well, a couple of things will happen.
One, you may be unsuccessful
with your business,
and you may decide that
you wanna do college.
And as long as you have the humility
to be a 22 year old freshman,
then you can go to college.
College will always be there.
The number one thing
that holds back people
from doing what they want is valuing
the judgment of other people.
As long as you have the humility
to be a 22 year old freshman in college,
then you should do your business.
And again, what's putting pressure on you
is the way your friends
are living right now.
But I always believe
that somebody else's life
really has no impact on yours.
You chose this for a reason don't bail
just 'cause it's inconvenient.
- [Fan] Cause I wanted
to do something different
than definitely everyone is doing.
- Well, the question is,
are you doing it 'cause you wanna do
something that's different,
or are you doing it
because you want to do it?
- [Fan] Both.
- Well good then you're perfect.
(mellow music)
I thought it was D Rock.
I was like D Rock, come on.
- [Interviewer] Gary Vee,
welcome to (indistinct) show.
- Thanks for having me.
- [Interviewer] There
are a couple of concerns
about the Metaverse and this world,
which is data security for instance.
And another thing, you
always talk about positivity,
good values as well.
Will that be there in the Metaverse?
It cannot be controlled maybe.
- One thing that will
never be decentralized
is human behavior.
Of course there's gonna be
bad behavior in the Metaverse,
there's bad behavior everywhere.
Humans are flawed.
People do things when they're unhappy,
people do things when they're desperate.
And so I think it's fascinating
to watch people judge platforms,
for things that humans are actually doing.
Social media hasn't changed people
the way that people want to say it is.
It's exploiting the truth,
which is people are
showing their true actions
and that will happen on the Metaverse.
♪ Wait for them to catch me, let it rain ♪
♪ Let it rain ♪
♪ All my niggas reaching just to stay ♪
♪ Was it real or was it
fake, don't know the diff ♪
♪ All that talking, all that chatting ♪
♪ That's a mess ♪
(indistinct singing)
(audience cheering)
- It's great to have you here.
Thank you for time to be with us Gary.
- It is super lovely
to be with all of you,
thank you so much.
The rules of the world on when you should
have your life figured out,
when you should be married,
have children, make money, buy a home,
and everything else
are based completely on
when people live to 45
and 55 years old, period.
The problem with that
is we're living to 100.
The concept that a 25 year old
should have everything
figured out is laughable.
Most 60 year olds I know don't
have their life figured out.
Why are 25 year olds
putting such pressure?
I think that we have societally
done a very poor job to our youth.
One of the great reasons
I struggle with the way
that education is sold in our society
is we train kids from a very young age
that you will be judged every
90 days on your actions.
I think it leads to very,
very vulnerable behavior
that maps to our adulthood.
So yes, I think that way too many people
are judging themselves in the short term.
Yes, I believe that if
you are 63 years old,
you still have 30 years to achieve
fulfillment and happiness.
And I think it's time that we have
a totally different
conversation around age.
To the point where in actuality,
the fact that we pressure
children into starting
to get serious at 22
is actually ludicrous.
22 to 30 should be wild, high risk,
high reward behavior
because it's practical.
Because even if you blow
it and nothing goes well,
you can start getting serious at 30, 35.
And so we ask people to now
you're a grown up get a real job,
and all this other ludicrous behavior
that I think has really hurt society.
I think it's quite depressing,
for lack of a better word,
that there are people
that are 40 years old
still have 60 years ahead of
them and they think it's over.
I think that needs to stop.
(audience applauding)
(mellow music)
♪ Piling paper got them
talking nice to me ♪
♪ Down a bottle it be
going right through me ♪
♪ Brown baby down to take a flight to me ♪
Just did a CNN piece with
Becky talking about NFTs.
When you're talking to
the mainstream media,
the majority of people
watching are hearing about
NFTs for the first time.
So you're really trying to go to 101,
and you're also trying to
answer a lot of the skepticism.
Most of her interview with me just now
was a lot of, "It's a
Ponzi scheme, right?"
And you get a lot of that
and I understand that,
and I think that's the
trials and tribulations
of being a communicator in
new emerging technologies.
People always face them with cynicism,
especially with the amount of money
that's being thrown around.
For me these are huge moments in my career
because you're really putting
yourself on the record,
no longer just in digital
but really in the mainstream media.
And I get excited about these moments,
'cause I know that I
get to look back at them
in five, seven, 12 years
when these things play out,
and it becomes a I told you so moment.
Or mentally, and this is
important for all of you to hear,
I'm always prepared for
me losing my fastball.
Is this gonna be the
thing I'm wrong about?
And I have to be mentally prepared for
making unbelievable amounts of
content in seven to 12 years
if NFTs don't hit and
talk about what I misread.
Why was I wrong?
But this is very clear to me,
the macro of the consumer
blockchain of NFTs is 100%.
99% of the projects are gonna fail,
there's a gold rush, there's
a lot of greed right now.
But that's no different
than internet stocks in '99,
the pets.com's of the world.
And so I continue to story tell in Dubai,
on the vlog with D Rock, on CNN,
or anywhere else that they'll have me.
That's cool.
♪ I don't understand it
how they got so timid ♪
♪ I told them I would do
it, then I overdid it ♪
♪ I did it ♪
♪ I don't do the base cause
I don't got the minutes ♪
I'll be very honest with you,
I feel more, more as an artist
than I do as a business man.
I'm incredibly empathetic
to people thinking
that I might be forcing that narrative
because I'm doodling now.
But I've always spoke
about being an entrepreneur
as more of being an artist
than a business person.
- [Guest] And IP and
characters, and all that stuff
has always been.
- But even forget about the literal,
I'm an artist, I innovate, I create.
My advertising agency
is profoundly artistic.
It is an enormous company,
one of the biggest
agencies now in the world.
This is not a joke,
it literally does
something nobody else does.
We are completely social
media first up to television,
we completely disagree with everything.
The covers of magazines say
I'm wrong, wrong, wrong, wrong, wrong.
I'm an artist.
- [Guest] Yeah.
You know the perception
from the people around how
you cannot be an artist and
entrepreneur at the same time.
- I know, meanwhile I think
the best artists in the world
are entrepreneurs, and
vice versa by the way.
And honestly I think my
art more than anything,
more than the doodles, more
than the entrepreneurship.
I think when it's all said and done,
my art is going to be in the way
I communicate it to the world.
♪ They don't want no static
better to get the signal ♪
♪ Indeed ♪
♪ Earning all these points
it ain't coincidental ♪
♪ It ain't ♪
♪ Tell them free to doggies,
keep them out the kennel ♪
- I know you're big on an NFTs,
you're working on something.
Any advice you can give at all?
- Yeah, I think the
biggest problem right now
is everyone's thinking
about what's in it for them
and not what's in it for
the people that buy it.
I would spend every second
on what's in it for them,
and why is it gonna work for them?
And the more that your energy is selfless
instead of selfish,
the more likely you'll put
together the strategies
that actually make the project successful.
- Yeah.
- Everyone's so greed-oriented now,
they see the gold rush.
Which is why they're gonna build projects
that are not gonna be meaningful.
So yes, I do have an out
of the blue quick take,
fucking think about them, them, them.
♪ Hit up draft kings,
I bet 100 on myself ♪
- Hey y'all, so at this point in the day
it's around noon in Dubai.
And this is the day after
Gary's interview with CNBC
dropped on all channels.
Gary's seeing the early
numbers from the US,
it's not even 5:00 a.m. in New York
and the video's already going super viral.
You might have seen it around.
- I wanna ask you about the
Bitcoin slash crypto boom
that we've seen over the
last couple of years.
At this point it's an avenue,
not just to make a lot of
money or lose a lot of money,
but it's also an avenue
for money laundering.
And it's also a place
where white supremacists
apparently are taking options.
It's problematic at best in so many ways.
How do you see what's happening
in the crypto space today?
- I don't think the crypto space
has any more problematic
issues than the internet,
society at large, mainstream
media, wall street.
I think it's a new avenue of innovation,
and I think every avenue of innovation
has good characters and bad characters.
How do I look at it?
I look at it as a new platform
where consumers and humans will evolve.
And all the good and the bad
that comes along with human behavior
will play out on the platforms.
- Or, maybe you've seen a
couple of memes made out of it,
and so this is when
Gary is starting to see
the early reactions.
He's starting to realize that
this clip has some traction,
and this is what he has to say about it.
- It's gonna have a lot of views,
and just the whole tone of
it is, "This is all bullshit,
and it's the least bullshit of all time."
This reaction is, I just know consumers.
You know me, I don't give
a about any of my shit,
I'm reacting to the reaction.
- [Maha] Yeah.
- It just hit a tone.
♪ I've been all alone ♪
♪ Ain't never need nobody else ♪
♪ I'm at the top floor sipping
margaritas off the shelf ♪
♪ Wish I had some competition ♪
♪ But it ain't nobody low ♪
♪ Hit up Draft Kings,
I bet 100 on myself ♪
♪ I been all alone, ain't
never need nobody else ♪
That's unbelievable.
- [Cryo Lab Guide] So you
might have done cryo chambers.
I don't know if you've used one before.
- [Gary] I have.
- [Cryo Lab Guide] They're say 140 minus,
this will feel colder because
of the sheer volume of them.
- God, that's interesting.
- [Cryo Lab Guide] If you guys
wanna have a go, we can...
- Let's get in there D Rock,
it will be some good content.
- The world's largest cryo.
- [Cryo Lab Guide] Okay,
do you wanna jump in?
- Yep.
- [Cryo Lab Guide] Yeah.
- Let's go D Rock.
(mellow music)
- [Maha] G, how was it?
- [Gary] Phenomenal.
- [D Rock] Yeah, that was great.
- [Maha] I know, but you weren't cold?
- [D Rock] No, listen, you walk through--
- It was whole lot of
competitive juices flowing
in that cryo chamber.
Somebody was willing to die.
(group laughing)
♪ All in 20s, come around,
I bet she love it ♪
♪ Hey, boosting up my ego,
can't be seen in public ♪
♪ This a brand new whip so
please don't lean on it ♪
♪ AMG a big cat with some strings on it ♪
♪ She said that I'm toxic but
want me to put a ring on it ♪
♪ A-K-A her favorite color pink ♪
♪ But she like green on it ♪
♪ We gon' throw a party ♪
Why did you first start diving?
- My father was a commercial diver.
And if you have been in Stockholm,
there is a museum called the Vasa museum,
with an ancient shipwreck that sank.
And he took me up there
and showed me this once,
so that's when I got hooked,
and said I want to do the same.
- [Gary] That's cool.
- And I actually discovered
an even more famous shipwreck than he did.
And it's called the discovery
of the century, in 2011.
I spent 20 years to search
for it and then I found it.
- [Gary] Come on.
That must have been an
incredible feeling for you.
- Yeah it was, when you
spend so many years.
- [Gary] 20 years, and then you found it.
- Yeah, yeah.
Everyone said it was impossible,
because the Navy searched for
it, all the treasure hunters,
all the big companies
tried to search for it.
And then we found it.
- And is there gold in all
sorts of crazy shit down there?
- Yeah, the crazy thing is
that it had 4,000 gold coins,
it had 200,000 silver coins.
One of these silver coins
is valued to €13,000.
- [D Rock] Wow.
- So imagine the cost.
But it's all protected down there.
If this ship would have
sunk 500 meters to the east.
- [D Rock] Yeah.
- I would own that.
- No way.
Is that true?
- Yeah, because then it would be outside
the territorial waters.
- [D Rock] Oh my God.
- That's how it is.
Push it, push it, push it.
But the goal was to find this shipwreck,
it was never about the money for me.
- Right, what a story.
Thank you for sharing.
- [Johan] Thank you for appreciating it.
- Thank you for sharing it.
(mellow music)
All right, good news, I
found the turtle's father.
(Man In Green laughing)
And we've made peace, me and
the turtles are good now.
- It's okay, no beef anymore.
- It's all family.
- Yeah, I know, all good.
- This is not a debate,
you get more with honey than vinegar.
You may be confused
because when you sell fear,
you are able to get very
quick micro results.
It's not a sustainable framework,
and so I think there's an evolution.
The problem is most
leaders today are scared
to deploy soft skills
because they're dealing
with a couple of things.
One, it's not the
environment they grew up in,
two, they're incredibly worried
about the entitlement
of the young generation.
So they're scared to
give them even an inch,
which is a really interesting tightrope.
But if you can nuance it,
you can actually get a lot more from it.
Because, for example, in
my 1500 person environment,
I had an employee come
to me asking for one year
paternity and maternity leave
'cause Netflix and Facebook did it.
It was because I deal with such kindness
in all these frameworks,
it allowed that meeting
to be three seconds.
I explained to her that
Netflix and Facebook
make more money in an hour than
our company makes in a year.
And the meeting was over
in a positive manner,
because everything else is so positive
that when they get any
level of pushback from me
it lands better.
(mellow music)
♪ Something that you do to
me, do to me, do to me ♪
♪ Got me feeling like
it ain't nothing new ♪
♪ Because I got money on mind ♪
♪ Shooters are behind ♪
♪ Been through the mud ♪
♪ And now I'm growing in sunshine ♪
♪ Got it out ♪
♪ He like that hustle when I wear it out ♪
♪ These diamonds paid up
front, ain't no clout ♪
♪ Don't worry about what I'm getting now ♪
♪ 'Cause it ain't no doubt,
I'm whipping that shit ♪
♪ Flipping that shit, I'm the bitch ♪
♪ That you've been heard 'bout ♪
♪ 'Cause my shoes, bags, baby Dior ♪
♪ And I don't work at the store ♪
♪ They waiting on me, of course ♪
Herm, show me where the line--
Oh.
- That's you, that's a you problem.
- This fucking ass.
Don't touch it.
- Oh sorry, I'll make it worse?
- Yes, that would make it worse.
- [D Rock] White wine,
you need white wine.
- I know what I need.
- [Herm] D Rock?
- Fucking Herm.
♪ Baby, got me feeling
like the right time ♪
♪ Something that you do to me ♪
Most people's biggest thing
that they're missing is humility.
Everybody wants to act
like they're successful,
everyone's spending more
energy thinking about
how to take a photo that
makes them look successful
than actually fucking becoming successful.
The way you're gonna be in
a nine to five this young
and build an empire is
gonna be about patience,
execution, humility.
It takes a lot of work.
- [Sean] What's up bro?
- It's good to see you.
- [Sean] It's so cool to
see this in person.
- Are you well?
- Yeah, I'm good, I'm good, man.
- It's so good to see you
bro, I'm proud of you.
- I appreciate that.
- Keep pushing, you've
really, really got good vibes.
- I saw you were coming to LA,
so I was like, "Bro, I gotta stop by."
I really appreciate it.
- I'm really proud of you, keep pushing.
- Thank you, I really appreciate it.
- Stay patient too, you're so young.
- I got you.
- You got so much opportunity.
- I really appreciate it.
- I see a lot of light in you.
- I'll make you proud.
- You already made me
proud, just keep going.
- Thank you my man.
- D Rock, you gotta see, yo!
Grab him.
- [Group Member] Yeah, you
gotta get that on film.
(crowd cheering)
- I got an official VeeFriend
from the man himself.
- All right, let me read this,
one, how do I bounce back?
- [Fan] That's the only
question I ever have
for successful people.
- [Gary] it's a really
simple game bro.
You have to allow yourself
to be okay with grieving,
and when you're ready you're ready.
People demonize grieving,
you should grieve as long as you need to.
Everybody will tell you
the wrong thing on this,
da, da, da, da, da.
You're allowed to grieve bro, it's tragic.
I tell my team all the time,
when the real shit happens to
me and I lose somebody I love,
be prepared for me being ghost for a year.
I don't know how long it's gonna take,
but I'm not gonna be tough guy
come in the next fucking day.
Allow yourself to grieve.
Don't worry about other people's opinions
about your fucking grieving.
Grieve, get that shit out.
Swim, meditate, eat,
do whatever the you need to do.
Grieve.
Give yourself permission to grieve.
You're a young dude,
you got plenty of time.
- [Fan] You over here
and you got me crying.
- [Gary] It's a pleasure, bro.
- [Crowd] Gary, Gary,
Gary, Gary, Gary, Gary!
Gary, Gary!
♪ Hop in a car to the seaside ♪
♪ It's a rollercoaster ride ♪
♪ Taking a risk for the low tide ♪
♪ Off the hopes of a better life ♪
♪ Alternate, change of plan ♪
♪ I have to go and recreate ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
- [Announcer] This is the
incomparable Gary Vee.
(group cheering)
- It's good to be here,
I hope everyone's good.
Just wanna chop a little
bit on NFTs and music.
20 years ago people signed deals fast,
now they signed deals
a little slower, right?
People are a little bit more thoughtful
trying to build more leverage.
Once everybody in this room and this space
understands what I just talked about
it doesn't matter what
the language is gonna say.
You're never gonna sign the
deal in the first place.
When you just know like, "Yo,
let's just sell it to our fans."
When you have 7,000,000
followers on TikTok,
you're gonna find 10,000
people that are gonna give you
800 bucks for a piece of your backend.
800 bucks times 10,000 adds up.
This is what every artist will aspire to,
people instead of aiming for a deal
will settle for a deal
if they weren't able to
sell or big enough fan bases.
Now you're doing the royalty thing,
with music think about
how it's gonna work out.
This is why the artist is gonna win twice.
Now you put out the NFTs
for the percentages of the backend.
You pop off, now people
are just gonna run math,
and be like, "Okay,
this artist hasn't even hit the apex yet.
They've got historical data.
I think this artist could be number one
for another 13 weeks."
They're gonna run back the math,
figure out what Spotify's kicking you.
They're gonna be like, "Fuck it,
I'll buy his NFT for 50%
more than it is right now.
'Cause I know I'll make
it back in 15 weeks."
And so you bought an NFT for
400 bucks to get a piece,
now you're selling it for 4,000.
You made some money on royalties,
and you sold the NFT for 4,000,
but the artist gets $400 on
that transaction, or $200,
depends on what the
math is on the royalty.
There's double royalty
economics for the artist,
the contract they make money
on every time it transacts,
and obviously the royalties of the music.
So now an artist could
be playing in two places.
(audience applauding)
♪ Hop in a car to the west ♪
♪ No, I do not have regrets ♪
♪ Chasing nickels and a dream ♪
♪ Got no problems in between ♪
♪ Mama said I always had
a lot of pride, yeah ♪
♪ She like, baby, none of
this is a surprise, yeah ♪
♪ Hop in a car to the west,
no I do not have regrets ♪
♪ Chasing nickels and dream ♪
♪ But no problems in between ♪
♪ Mama said I always had a lot of pride ♪
♪ She like, baby, none
of this is a surprise ♪
♪ Mm mm ♪
(mellow music)
Is there any utility?
- [Man In Cap] Tons of utility,
festival, building dinners,
monthly meet up.
- For green street?
- [Man In Cap] Yeah, for
the Vanity Record, yeah.
(mellow music)
- [Fan] Can you (indistinct)
the smiley face?
Oh my God, Mr. Vee, Mr. Vee.
- Did you see what I did there D Rock?
I incorporated the Vee into the hair.
- [Fan] Thank you so much.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
(upbeat Spanish music)
- [Crowd Member] Gary Vee.
- What's up fam?
- Gary Vee man.
My name is Slink Johnson,
an actor, comedian.
You fucking inspirating and motivating,
you tell real shit.
I'm a procrastinator,
and I be fucking up bro.
(Gary laughing)
But you say the right shit.
Can we take a picture Gary Vee?
I'm a procrastinator.
Gary Vee, thank you man.
- [Gary] Dude, thank you man.
Looking sharp bro,
you looking good bro.
- Thank you bro, I stole this.
This jacket came with an eviction notice.
It did, thank you bro.
- My dude, keep that humor going.
♪ It ain't no thing to do my thing ♪
♪ It's what I do the best ♪
♪ I fill my matches, pay my taxes ♪
♪ Then I blew the rest, damn right ♪
♪ And it's okay to do ♪
- What's up boy?
- [Gary] What's up?
What's up legend?
- How you doing brother?
- Hey fam, it's great to see you.
- Hey, my pleasure man.
Always a motherfucking treat.
- Congrats on this bro.
- Thank you.
- So fucking proud of you,
that 360 shit is crazy,
I'm so proud of you bro.
- What we gonna do now?
- We're gonna fucking
make it number one again.
- What we gonna do now?
- Make it number one again.
My man.
Real pleasure, good to see you.
♪ Beat the game, learn
the game, play the game ♪
♪ Sell the game, all that. ♪
Oh D Rock.
♪ Change all that ♪
♪ Feeling myself, they be feeling me too ♪
I love you fam, for real.
I cheer for you daily, daily, for real.
You know it.
- What up y'all?
This is big Snoop Dogg, and
you know what time it is.
Be ready for Veecon, we
coming at you live and direct,
you better know it.
- The legend's coming.
- I'm coming, live.
(mellow music)